so Emily returning to your Screen Actors
Guild Award winning role yeah no
pressure right it's in my closet in your
closet yeah it's not like put that away
it's in there but I think maybe I'll put
it in somewhere a little more revealing
but I also get a bit embarrassed with
people being like oh we get it you know
what the kids play with it that's a
weapon not ship I mean returning to this
role is there one sequels there's a lot
of pressure this role too is the same
pressure come back to it I think so I
mean I think no one was under more
pressure than John I think that III
think it was a fairly impossible task
which is why I'm so surprised even proud
of him because I think he had to go into
it with a lot of ambition a lot of
courage and and conviction you know that
people want to see this as an investment
in this family as an investment in this
incredible world that you can expand on
but I don't see this as a sequel I see
that it's a continuation this is just
like what happens next
yeah you know no I read no I don't
forgot this great that you said this is
the most daunting thing you've done on
film this movie because like what do you
how do you top the giving birth in the
bathtub after you step on a nail I mean
I don't know maybe get you kid corner
back like I remember when he first wrote
the bear trap sequence I went oh my god
that's that's the nail that's the nail I
mean that's horrifying like that that
was a tough week shooting that so it was
this a little bit easier no no this
one's more physical I feel like there's
a lot of running and so much running I'm
still getting physical therapy on my
knee during this film yeah I remember
doing the batter up running and running
in bare feet and stuff and John was like
can you do like a fake stumble this was
I did a fixed I'm totally jacked my
knees oh yeah ridiculous yes walkers
calm I remember Killian even being like
he had to do a couple of mad Sprint's
you know and he's suddenly he's such a
trooper and just there was wonderful
person such a pro never complains but
John was like he okay killed you need a
break and he goes I just just dying from
mild heart attack right now just it was
just killing and I both talked about how
we felt our age on this one yeah yeah so
how did that ask John this question but
between you and John who has more
trouble being quiet like who puts the
foot in the mouth more can you in John
he answered he knows not to throw me
under the bus I said you do way better
in this situation he he he's right well
congratulations thank you